I think mr. Collins did a really good
job pointing out the immensely
complicated nature of the personal world
I love us that people face but I'm
wondering what happens when those
individuals become the heads of
corporations and have to try to figure
out how to apply their own ethical
standards to their corporate life while
still realizing that the point of the
corporation is to maximize its profits
and if there's such a great distinction
between what we should be doing on a
personal level and what we should be
doing through our jobs and he doesn't
that create a sort of tension within the
individual it might be problematic yeah
I guess I'm creeping more often than you
would but I can imagine but uh but I
certainly I certainly agree with you
that uh that you know in the case where
there is a functioning government which
limits the the actions of corporations
or in to protect citizens obviously it's
you know it's the imperative for the
cooperation to only think about profits
but I think what miss bethe points out
is that you know in many many
governments around the world knew
including I'd say the United States um
you know that sort of responsible
government simply doesn't exist and it
would be my view that you know minimus
betas proposal to say that you know well
a whole lot of companies have sort of
you know come together in a particular
country and decided they would like a
government that you know restricts their
actions so they can operate under
certain standards because they agree
that you know profits probably aren't
going to change and the public image
will be bolstered and the fallout from
not participating this framework will be
some sort of disincentive whether it be
you know the media will suddenly jump on
the bat bandwagon of BP is not acting
responsibly while its competitors are
like I find that a good market structure
in the absence of a government which
doesn't respect and implement the
disincentives that it should
so came back a little bit off mark and
Aaron earlier I'm really issuing
interested in issue of accountability
and I think it's well it's flawed to say
that we can't hold corporations
accountable and shouldn't and so you
look at slavery in the US for example
the end of slavery happened government
accomplished it and JP Morgan was
profiting off the continuation of
slavery illegally in the US and and so
kind of Mark's point we can't rely on
good governance because we used to be
constantly have to struggle for it but
it's not there and it's in the global
environment I think we also have to
acknowledge that we were there's a power
structure involved in which certain
nations have those that power and from
in the US this one one of the
predominant ones and so when its
interests are invested in corporate
interests that that could mean maybe you
know social responsibility isn't in the
favor of the government so how do we
beyond a framework because you know
there's no teeth to to this how do we
hold corporations accountable on the
Friedmann issue about where i see it
kind of falling apart is kind of so he
argues that the corporations aren't
built for this type of activity to build
social responsible enterprise but if
they're able to do have a functioning
unit for a lobbying on the other side of
the equation that proves to me that they
are capable of dealing with this because
they do recognize that it's someone in
their interest to continue these
processes so if they can't engage on the
issue why can't they get engaged the
other way on the issue and secondly one
of the biggest problems I'm having I
think I'm falling in line with the u.s.
later about kind of they do no harm
principle it seems like the way we're
looking at and what you're talking about
mr. Collins is kind of boycott not Nike
do activity on the back end versus on
the the preventive end and we're
constantly seeing more harm continue to
happen and then you have a campaign to
say no don't do that and eventually that
public pressure comes and then they stop
but the harms already been done and
harmed
again and again again and how do we
break that cycle if we're gonna follow
that mindset of it's gonna be checked on
the ops other side versus on prevented
respond yeah almost a couple these
comments together and talk the point
about accountability and talking about
or that we're talking about trying to
create systemic change but that is
prevented it open incorporates
accountability and I think it is partly
what Mark said that it's going to be a
spectrum of tools that would hold
companies accountable I mean part of
what has been interesting to watch this
debate over the past few years is that
again it started off with here's an
international treaty this is this is the
answer and that if we make this
international law and then countries
ratify it and then it will be the tool
right and so what John where you said is
actually actually that's not that's not
gonna work there's there's no feasible
enforcement mechanism at the
international level hold companies
accountable and that's actually part of
how we got into this trouble in the
first place is that you know regulation
and legislation is by definition
national and now business is global and
that there are all sorts of you know
loopholes and complications in trying to
regulate international business so
that's how we got in this trouble in the
first place is that there are governance
gaps for international business so one
one thing so he stepped back and said
okay what is what is out there not let's
not start from an advocacy point of view
what do we wish is out there but what is
actually out there and so the the report
you might be most interested in was this
report in 2007 and by the way all of his
all this stuff is archived at this
fantastic web portal called the business
and Human Rights Resource Center and I
don't pay me for saying that
in 2007 report tried to map this
spectrum to move everybody beyond you
know we need to live long we don't need
early long to say okay here are the ways
in which corporations are held
accountable with respect to human rights
and there is a spectrum of them so on
the one hand we can look all the way
over to corporate accountability for
international crimes and they're you
know as more and more countries ratify
the International Criminal Court statute
where some countries provide for
criminal prosecution of legal persons as
well as natural persons then companies
can be held accountable for
international crime so looking at
jurisdictions where that is in place
drawing on some really good studies that
are out there that are also posted on
that site then moving into national law
for for other kinds of not the worst
forms of human rights abuses but other
forms of legal accountability then
moving into sort of soft law and other
tools that don't have the force of hard
law but there are some international
mechanisms like the OECD guidelines for
multinational enterprises you know they
have they have some accountability
mechanisms there are people who
investigate complaints and they're
supposed to hand down some kind of
sanctions like some of these industry
initiatives now have some form of
accountability so if a company signs up
to one of these initiatives they're
supposed to do some reporting they're
supposed to demonstrate their progress
if they don't do that you know they can
get kicked out which some might say it's
not a real form of accountability but
actually for companies it is it's a
reputational hit and if you say you're
going to do something you know you you
do it in part because of your consumers
and in part because now increasingly
companies are getting sued simply for
not doing what they say they're doing
and then moving into voluntary
regulation by companies but at an
industry or at an individual company
level and again the point being that if
companies say they're gonna do something
you know there is some sense that there
there will be sanctions in some form
whether they're legal or not that they
will do it so that's the that's the
point really is that there is a spectrum
of ways in which for
operations can and should be held
accountable for human rights and that
will always be the case that there's a
whole spectrum we need to look at that
whole spectrum and see where their gaps
and where can the things that exist be
strengthened in the mechanisms there's
still the need for the vernacular and
the framework within which any of these
meant because without it without them
almost any of these mechanisms are going
to be greatly impaired so it's agreeing
the fundamental principles that underlie
all these I think I do it I think it's a
lot less complicated than that I think
it's you know you could you can have the
myth that corporations have this you
know so or intentionality
you just wouldn't get anything done and
you you I think you made a good point
and that is that you know a lot of this
stuff actually which is on the surface
the right thing to do for morale simple
it's also really good business and I
think there's educating people about
that is a really good thing that you
know if you actually treat your
employees well maybe there's a
short-term pain but you know we had a
business turnover was thirty five
percent we reduced the turnover by
paying people more and giving them
better health care to four percent and
our training costs went down and
productivity went up and so forth and so
on is the word so there's a there's some
of that but I think in reality there are
really difficult choices to make as an
individual you know I mean what I would
have a hard time frankly working for an
oil company or a cigarette company or
you know I mean I just couldn't do it I
couldn't work for a company that that
owned big operations in China that was
shipping arms to the Jinja we'd you know
just couldn't do it
so I think it's a it's a it's a question
of being realistic about where you can
make a difference there are enormous
problems for more now than ever before
there
or you know there are slaves there are
as poverty their children dying of
malaria there are people losing their
homes because they were screwed by some
you know Wall Street firm there are you
know just these gigantic environmental
problems so I mean there's just a lot to
do I just think given that there's a lot
to do this is a great thing to do is to
focus your attention on where the
leverage really are and they're in
government they're in the United Nations
which can impose sanctions and raise the
level of the debate where people will
create sanctions you know independently
and individually minute that that's
there's just there's there's so much to
do that you need to focus your
ammunition on the place where it's
actually going to be efficacious I
happen to think you know and I've done a
lot of sort of empirical analysis about
where I could personally spend my time
yeah and and resources the most
effectively and for the last six months
I concluded that I was getting you know
a Democrat in the White House and a huge
majority in the Senate and then you know
putting leverage in that or spending
time and you know in Beirut or Jerusalem
or you know Cairo understanding you know
the dilemma there buddy I mean
everybody's got their own way to do it
but but but having a fairy tale is
counterproductive